blizzard warnings are in effect from
North Carolina to Maine as this huge
winter storm moves up the East Coast
this morning drivers are facing a very
difficult commute as you can see here is
a look from the Jersey Shore in a moment
we're gonna check back in with Tony to
copal who is on the beach getting
hammered by blizzard conditions right
now but first chief weather caster
Lonnie Quinn of our New York station
WCBS has a look at the science behind
today's extreme weather
Lonnie good morning well good morning
everybody no doubt the two biggest terms
that you've probably heard about this
storm our bomb cyclone and blizzards so
let's talk about how those two are
interconnected
bobak Genesis is a rapidly strengthening
storm it's a hurricane as the snow storm
doesn't really matter and when a storm
strengthens the column of air in the
center of that storm rises faster and
faster and faster that air rises the
more turbulent that storm becomes and
storms that are weather bombs they come
with powerful winds because that rapidly
rising air well it has to be replaced by
air from outside the storm so in essence
they create their own wind and those
winds need to be at least 35 miles per
hour
now the second component of a blizzard
is visibility less than a quarter of a
mile all due to blowing snow
now both both the wind and that decrease
visibility has got to last for at least
three consecutive hours personally I
think it's pretty interesting to note
that you do not need to have falling
snow or or even large snow totals to
have a blizzard so when it comes to a
bomb cyclone and a blizzard yes you can
have one without the other
and they can be pretty darn dangerous
look at this you can barely see me but
you know right here in the Northeast
they do tend to go hand-in-hand
Nora Lonnie that may be the best live
shot you've ever done the first well
done